it's funny because wrestlers will be in
the locker room and they're all oh
and they're taping up knees and things
like oh they go into the ring
and they're superheroes yeah they go
back they're all bleeding and everything
more blood everywhere more so good
um yeah stunt people and pro wrestlers
it's
what a life what a life
what a life egg credits role
i mean i mean i suppose like pro
wrestlers is just a natural evolution of
stuntman right because
because it's just like it's more
controlled stunts and you add a
narrative to it
i felt that way and also the guys who
tend to go into stunts tend to be much
more like talented with the physical
stuff and i was better at the
character performance right so for me it
seemed like a much more natural
evolution all right what are some of the
craziest stunts you've had to do
um well i wasn't that good so i didn't
get to do that
much right jumping off balconies done
some of that
it's not that hard um i mean i don't
know i don't know i wouldn't want to
i wouldn't want to jump off a balcony
personally how tall are we talking here
not that tall second story
he's doing like 20 stories of things
this is how real chad does it oh my god
man it was never good enough
some people are just like cockroaches
right they just can't die
honestly like honestly it's like in pro
wrestling i hit over the head with one
of those fluorescent light tubes
right that was good that actually
doesn't hurt but it does cut you so
yeah we end up leading okay um that's
very awkward
have you ever gotten injured or anything
like that like properly like
yeah uh well i've probably been
concussed but didn't realize
what i'm saying okay have you not had
that's whole thing a concussion you
don't know what's going on right you
need someone to stop you and be like
you're concussed
we need to do the whatever we just do
what people have done a first aid course
like people who play american football
like never know their cast exactly
yeah oh geez i think it's like they have
like the most i think they die early
because they have so much brain damage
right hitting so it's the same with mma
fighters
training just getting jabbed just
getting a little punches they get like
compounded brain damage from that
not from getting knocked out it's from
just little shots over right right
um anyway so light over the head broken
glass
oh sorry not broken glass barbed wire
did some of that
like jesus yeah yeah i did that
hit with a shovel i got hit in the hair
with a shirt with a shovel it was a
great weapon
like how how hard are we talking like
just like a little like yeah
because because like it's a great weapon
but if you hit it with the concave side
it's not that bad on your skull the
convex side would really mess you up oh
yeah yeah
cave side you know folds out of your
skull right right but like to control
that right
in the swing would be i i feel a lot
harder than it looks
because like there's an image of pro
wrestling that you know progressing is
fake and everything like that but
obviously the stunts are real like
how hard do you have to go for the
stunts that you do in pro wrestling
depends it depends on what happens so
like you should give it hell really so
what you're saying the shovel right in
my mind my immediate thought is
guys swing shovel tries his best to stop
it but it still hits you
is that what's happening or is he
literally going like i'm gonna hit you
hit me as hard as you can
because i guess because i guess like the
audience needs to hear the sound right
yeah i hear the sound and also it's you
know
like just guessing on the sound board in
the back so you want to do it when you
when you're wrestling you want to do it
you know
there's an element of come on you know
no i don't that's why
that's why i'm not a pro wrestler that's
like that yeah i have a version
of the chat versus the version i think
you're looking for
anyone listening doesn't sound like a
verb
frankly i don't want to be hitting that
shot you know i used to love it
it's you know it's a young man's game
it's a young man you talk about this
like it's like a last time you know
is it you know when a kid says that it's
like oh god this kid's going nowhere
wow he's such a manly adult i feel like
if
if my son comes up to me at age five
daddy i love being hit in the head by a
shovel i'll be
is it just the sheer manly energy in the
testosterone going around
it's just like just hit [ __ ] hit me i
mean i guess once you're on the stage
it's like
i get it is the adrenaline going
adrenaline and there's something
uh somehow emotionally satisfying with
it as well
so from an acting standpoint acting is
all emotion and so forth right
right right um wrestling is the most
emotional work i've ever done
because there's so much emotion involved
in it's real it's real yeah oh yeah
it's real yeah yeah so it's highly
emotional and there's something
satisfying about it it's you know like i
said it's a young man's game
it's you you want to be doing that in
your 20s yeah i think what was it like
the journal of the thing on the wwe i
think i
watched that and it was saying that
they're like they're all contractors in
wwe they're not
really yeah yeah so they're they're all
they're contractors that can't work for
anyone else
okay and then you know once they're done
they don't really get much health
benefits or anything so a lot of them
end up you know being really injured
later on right right
see ya that's getting fixed nowadays i
hope so yeah
back in the day lots of that um but you
know there's something satisfying about
it i had
this was not you know really dangerous
but we found you know those
plastic wet floor signs the golden
triangle yeah yeah
those are fantastic weapons oh yeah i
mean because when you hit someone with
them the two pieces of plastic
clap together so it makes a really loud
noise doesn't hurt so it doesn't hurt
so you go crack crack crack he hit some
of the head with over and over again
so i did that in a match once it was
great okay hitting the head a bunch of
times right
hey we did this this this spot then
later on i'm going home i'm on the train
and there's some like young girl next to
me she sits down next to me
she's like and i'm like
how are you she's like
i think she got up like change seats or
something i was like
and then like we got off at the station
and i walked past some reflective
surface
and i'm not talking about this we walked
past some reflective circus my whole
like face had turned purple the whole
purple
she's like mega
people from foreign
yeah jesus christ i did a gimmick with
fire once but that wasn't that wasn't
bad from a pain perspective
you said it wasn't bad from a pain
perspective what was it bad
okay what perspective was it bad in one
insurance perspective
that's the perspective for which it was
bad you'll never wrestle in this
building again
all right i've been doing anything with
fire most 90
of the time requires some kind of safety
firewood
we just thought it would be fantastic we
had a
stick with a cloth wrapped around it
that been drenched in
gasoline or something
there's a fire truck right there the
bucket of water the piss bucket on the
side
i've just gone on stage and take taking
your like insurance insurance
like and just said that
we had a thing one time with just
needles we used needles
there's a shower at the facility i just
i just wash it off
in japan that's what most of them are
like the death the death about death
match workers in japan right that's what
they're like they'll go into the ring be
bleeding everywhere
and afterwards oh to go to the zoi
mustang
there's only two times when there's like
a [ __ ] ton of blood in the shower that's
at a wrestling match in
oh my god oh my god
now i'll leave that up to your
imagination
[Music]
anyway i was not thinking that that's
not what i was gonna say
i did not
he's been holding on to that joke for
years like i've never found a place to
see it today